how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
musical philosophy first of all how that
I guess in the fact that we're thinking
about sex robots that won't look human
maybe circumnavigates the problem the
other one but lots of people have which
is do these robots then have rights
because a blanket then we could start
start alan off in this topic topic well
I I mean I fundamentally I think robots
should not have rights ever robots are
not persons when I say ever I I mean not
I mean until we can build data from Star
Trek and does he really have rights he's
forced to work well he is labor
trafficked to he could it be programmed
to enjoy that so it doesn't matter if he
enjoys it it's the condition with which
he enters the work whether he likes the
work but it's so far into the future I
mean we can't build robots that know
what rights are let alone ask for them
so so and and that I mean it's a very
dangerous you know the the it's a
slippery slope toward robot rights
because with rights become come
responsibilities and so on and a
fundamental ethical principle that we
have right now is that humans not robots
are responsible and I think we we see I
mean there's been talking in the
newspapers and things about the European
Court deciding whether or not robots
have personhood and it's not personhood
in a rights way it's person hitting it
in a corporate personhood type of way so
responsibilities and insurance things
I'm sure it's yeah so there's a lot of
discussion to be done but I think the AI
community does seem to quite split on it
if you go on Twitter and watch a bit of
a wry going on between the people who
think that yes they absolutely should
and no they shouldn't and just before we
turn to the questions how likely is it
and how ubiquitous will it be but this
kind of technology robots in the form of
blankets or robots and robot
yeah how likely is it but everybody in
this room will have well so David Levy
who wrote one of the of the grime
breaking book on this called love and
sex with robots back in 2007 predicted
that by 2025 we'd all be marrying sex
robots I I there's number of reasons why
I think this is this is crazy not least
because mary's is on decline as well and
I think I think it's very problematic I
don't think that's gonna happen at all I
like David we get on well but I think
he's far too utopian in his visions I
think that then he realized that to 2050
but I think that's not you know we're
not gonna see that not with the humanoid
form
wearable extended sex technology much
more realistic we already see the start
of it now I've got some very cool sex
toys out there that are personalizable
customizable that mold to your body that
can be bent that can be shaped that it
and that's where I think the future is
it's about customizable and
personalizable technology that we can
use to enhance our sex lives
great so one of the biggest ethical
problems with robotics and AI right now
in my view is that it's mostly designed
by men in fact by men for men and as
part of I'm part of a number of groups
trying to develop approaches to what we
call ethically aligned design one of
those approaches is gender balance so I
would have a make a call if you like a
plea that our sex machines are designed
by teams balance
teams of men and women get your tickets
for the world's largest music and
philosophy festival how the light gets
in org